the iPhone 14 lineup is here with a
bunch of new changes but Max save is
honestly still my favorite feature of
all time because it literally makes my
life easier in so many different ways so
let's get started with the top 10 most
useful Max save accessories that we've
tested over the years as well as some
new ones number one is mothsnap Max safe
case and I included this because out of
all the cases that we've tested it by
far has the strongest magnets twice as
strong as apples so if you have issues
with Max safe not being strong enough
this is the case for you regardless of
which Max safe iPhone model you have or
which of the three colors you choose
from and that brings us to number two
which is our partner moth's snap power
set which is a combination of their
wallet stand and brand new battery bank
which is the only one on the market with
a nice vegan leather material alongside
the thin design and it has macsafe
magnets on both the front and the back
so you can easily layer moths wallet
stand behind the battery and turn it
into a charging stand that works with
three different angles which is only
possible because unlike other battery
packs mops put the USBC charging port on
the side so you can use your iPhone
vertically and when it's fully topped
off since it features pass-through
charging you can take the whole set with
you on the go since the snap power set
is fully modular with a clever and
efficient design with mobility in mind
allowing you to easily interchange them
if you want to put the battery away for
later use and just use the wallet stand
which by the way we've been using and
showing off for a couple of years
already since it not only works as a
stand but it can also be used as a phone
grip with a total of 15 different colors
to match your new iPhone 14 color so
check out the moft Snap power set using
the link in the description below now
moving on to number three we have the
sinjamaro max safe sticker which is
basically meant to add Max 8 magnets to
older phones that don't have Max save so
you can actually use the maximum
accessories in this video and even
better countless people have used this
macsafe sticker to add magnetic wireless
charging to their Android phones as well
since macsafe is currently exclusive to
Apple and no other smartphone brand can
match it or on the other hand let's say
you already have a case without Max
magnets built in this would essentially
add Max save to any case out there just
use the included guide to line it up
around the wireless charging coils on
the inside of the phone which you can
find using a teardown and you're good to
go getting into number four we have the
mag disk from our sponsor Galileo gear
which is the world's smallest folding
Max save charging stand that's made
completely out of anodized aluminum
which Fold It Down protects your macsafe
cable plug while being four quarters
thin and it unfolds into a 60 degree Max
safe charging stand so check it out in
the description below now for number
five we have the gooseneck Max stand
that we've previously tested and it's
just so useful that we had to show it
off again this accessory essentially
allows you to clamp the gooseneck down
anywhere you want to like a tabletop a
nightstand a bed frame a camera tripod a
fence or anywhere you can possibly
imagine and then you simply adjust the
impressively strong gooseneck into any
orientation you'd like you can even use
it for taking family photos on a timer
wherever you're at instead of having to
swap people around to take photos and
probably the most useful idea is to
position the mount over your bed to
enjoy videos or movies without having to
hold your iPhone or even better you can
position it next to your laptop or even
use it as your webcam for FaceTime by
simply pointing the rear camera at your
face and it's only 25 bucks on Amazon so
it's actually pretty inexpensive as well
now getting into number six we have the
weighty max safe carbon charger which
has been my single most favorite Maxim
accessory ever since I got one year
years ago and it's honestly so good that
I purchased a second one for my second
car because I missed it every time I
drove it so we had to get another one
since it's only 25 bucks on Amazon right
now and it literally comes with
everything you need including a 12 volt
power adapter with an additional Port
the charging cable and the max safe
wireless charging Mount itself with a
very convenient adjustable ball joint
for mounting into your van this Maxim
accessory has changed my life since I
like to use my iPhone naked and it
allows me to mount it next to my
steering wheel all while it actually
charges my iPhone as well and for just
25 dollars it's a steal of a deal now
for number seven we also have another
Max Save carvet Mount which Max has
recently switched to instead of using
the way T Max save charger like I have
and the reason he switched was because
he actually uses Apple carplay in his
truck which requires the lightning cable
to be plugged in to connect so wireless
charging doesn't really matter to him in
fact when he used to have the weighty
charger his icon 13 Pros display with
dimmed down because it would overheat
while using GPS so he would sometimes
use it unplugged anyway so the Belkin
Mount was perfect for him because it
features a stronger magnetic connection
and you can easily wrap your lightning
cable around it making it more
convenient to plug in now this one's a
bit more expensive at 40 bucks on Amazon
but it's made with higher build quality
and he absolutely loves it moving on to
the number eight top Max save accessory
it's actually Belkin's Max save Puck
charger which is meant to directly
compete with Apple's original Max save
Puck since it supports the full 15 watts
of wireless charging speed but it
actually charges faster in our testing
yes the Belkin charging puck charged the
iPhone 12 that we tested up to 100 30
minutes sooner than Apple's maxite
version not only that but the cable is
braided so it's higher quality than
Apples and it's 6.6 feet long instead of
three on Apple's version making it more
convenient to use and it has a nice
little strap so you can more
conveniently wrap it up for taking with
you on the go even better the magnetic
connection is actually stronger than
Apple's version since it's a bit thicker
and it comes with a built-in kickstand
which is a nice little touch for number
nine we have esr's three in one Halo
lock charger with cryo boost now we've
tested many three-in-one charges before
some at 150 and other at 50 bucks and
this is the best bang for the buck
because it's only sixty dollars with
some unique features like a built-in fan
which they call cryoboost which cools
down your phone while it's wirelessly
charging which will not only improve
battery longevity but it'll stop display
dimming while charging and it'll even
charge your iPhone faster since it won't
slow down due to excessive heat now we
were shocked by how nice this is for the
price because it uses actual real
aluminum parts it has an adjustable
Mount which is super convenient it has
magnetic alignment minutes for your air
pods and unlike many budget three in one
Chargers it comes with an included power
adapter on top of that the extra spacing
and clearance of the main Max a charger
is perfect for the huge camera bump on
the iPhone 14 pro so it won't bump into
it and the cooling fan is surprisingly
quiet but can also be shut off along
with the lights with this button right
here so I think it's the best three in
one charger for the price and now
finally we have number 10 which is the
Razer Max iPhone cooler which
magnetically attaches to the back of
your iPhone to cool it down and it
actually works incredibly well because
it comes with an electronic Peltier
cooling tile that's attached to an
aluminum heat sink and fan which gets
ice cold in seconds the main point of it
is to stop overheating and display
dimming on the iPhone while playing
games or whatever else which was a huge
issue with the iPhone 12 and it's still
around a bit today on the iPhone 14 pro
and this Max iPhone cooler stops say
adding on to that it also comes with
customizable RGB lighting and it uses
USB type c for power with a convenient
on and off switch so it's the best phone
cooler out there which you can find on
Amazon so there you guys go those were
our top 10 useful Max save accessories
for the iPhone 14 lineup and of course
any other iPhone with Max save so if you
found any of those interesting you'll
find links to all of them in the video
description and pinned comment below
once again thank you to moft and Galileo
gear for partnering up on this video be
sure to click the circle button to
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]